I've always wanted to protect nature
suddenly when you have your own child it
becomes personal and you you certainly
want to protect it for someone it's not
just because it's there my name is
Trevor McIntyre I'm 33 years old I come
from South Africa I am a zoologist and I
am currently working at the Alfred
Wegener Institute for polar and marine
research in Bremerhaven the thing that I
enjoy the most about working here is
there's a lot of freedom in the kinds of
research questions i can ask and answer
particular to my project the alfred
wegener assertiveness should be the best
choice they run the blushed and Bishop
all the logistics in supplying so
they're able to carry on fairly large
expedition is my main interest at the
moment is trying to find out how seals
are reacting to changes in their
physical environments at once so what we
do is we deploy satellite relay data
loggers on the moon these are little
tags that we that we glue onto the seals
so again we get an idea of what the
physical environment is
swimming in working in remote places
gives you quite a different perspective
of things just see nature and you have
bad weather to deal with them animals
are going to buy theater near some tough
things to get through as an experience
it's really something that just teaches
you a lot about who you are firstly and
where your real interests are my
daughter was 10 months old when we came
to Germany we found the social system to
be quite supportive in South Africa of
course we have different demographic
issues we're not really trying to
encourage too much population growth I
certainly like the sort of marine
atmosphere that you have in Omaha it's
nice to have a bit of a breeze and the
wind that makes you feel like you are a
bit closer to the ocean
being involved in science you learn to
think in a more critical way I think you
learn to question things and you want to
really get some proof some numbers
behind it
one of the stranger things I suppose it
this crime is is just competition and I
think it's always it's interesting if
you if you read other papers and you see
album and these these people had such a
great question that they're answered
with such an innovative way and then you
think man why didn't I think about you
know I could have done that we are
planning an expedition in the collage
turn it will last three months this is
the first field expedition since my
daughter's birth so it would be quite a
challenge being away from home for so
long